Before the break,
I asked you to make
an exorcism tutorial video.
So let's see what
you guys came up with.
Mamrie, let's start with you.
So, after you
clean the vomit off you
and pull the crucifix
out of your orifice,
be sure to exercise your fingers
by subscribing for more vids
that'll make your head spin.
Love you like an...
(deep voice): exor-sister.
The subscribe call to action
on that was flawless
-at the end.
-Thank you, thank you, sir.
Uh, all right,
Hannah, you're next.
Hey, guys, it's me, Hannah.
Today we're going to learn
how to you expel demons
that have overtaken
your mortal soul.
So let's get started first
with some incantations.
(speaking Latin)
(roaring)
Whew.
(chuckles)
Oh, wow.
Anyway, be sure to click "like"
and subscribe.
Uh, Grace, you're next.
Hey, guys, it's me again.
So, step one of today's tutorial
is to make sure that your friend
is, like, actually possessed
and not having, like, a seizure
or something else gross.
So once you rule out science
you can start shoving pencils
up their ass
until the demons are gone.
Like and subscribe
to my channel, not to Hannah's.
Thank you, bye.
There's-there's a...
The rivalry-- there's a rivalry
among exorcism videos.
I got... I think I have to give
everyone 5,000 points.
-Those were all fantastic.
-Yay! -Yay!
-(whoops)
-5,000 points?
Oh, 666.
-666.
-Aah! -Oh!